two flags Ukraine's and another Which
flies for them belonging to a group
which calls itself the Russian volunteer
Corps
they captured this vehicle from Russian
forces in a daring cross-border two-day
raid into Russia's Belgrade region
we are the same Russians as you the same
people as you we want our children to
grow up in peace and be free so they can
travel learn and live in a free country
in other words Russians fighting for
Ukraine against the Putin regime
Russia's Ministry of Defense claims
they've now pushed them back and killed
70. they call them Ukrainian
nationalists Ukraine says none of this
has anything to do with them but whoever
the Raiders were and whatever happened
to them they had artillery backup and
sufficient reinforcement to keep the
fight going into a second day
The Villages along the Belgard border
have long had to suffer a taste of
Russia's own medicine but never on this
kind of a scale and it does beg the
question given the huge amount of cash
recently spent on fortifying those
border defenses why it was still
perfectly possible to cross over
Russia's president today was busy
handing out medals to those Russians who
do want to fight for him
but there do seem to be some who don't
men known and wanted in Russia for their
far-right sympathies
controlling the commander-in-chief on
social media
ready to take up arms against him from
across the border in Ukraine
Dynamic day Sky News Moscow